ヤスコさんの車に付いてて、あれがすごい憧れだったんですって
私の車?
昔はフォードだからスフィックに付いてなかった
車の前に皆さん、馬好きの方付けましたね
実際に使ったやつだね
まだうちいっぱい持ってます
ありがとうございます
全部付けました
馬好きはああいうのを見ると、ここだけピンポイントで
静鉄があるなって
うちも玄関に必ずかけて静鉄を入れてます
演技がいいんでしょ?
そうなんです
って教えていただいたのでね
うちの全部、東京の家の玄関までね
入ったと思われて
いただいて
それも金メッキと銀メッキがあられて
嬉しいよね、ちょっとね
そう
えっと、やつごさんがんばって
気をつけてください
もちろんジャンプがあられてたらいいんだけど
ジャンプがあられてたらいいんだけど
うん
そういうのはどこで乗るんですか?
そのクラブで乗るの?
何?
馬に乗るときってどこで乗るんですか?
今はあの、だからどこかの
ジョークラブに属してないと
でもなんじゃない?
属してるの?
そこがあってそれで
馬に乗る
馬というところがあるんですよ
砂っぽいところが
そこに行ってられたり
今どこ入ってるんですか?
今もう入ってない
入ってないじゃん
千葉に行かれてましたもんね
そう、千葉では馬持ってたんだけどね
民宿のおじさん
うんうんうん
で、彼によると
すごいおばあちゃんは
よくうま
先人よりよく乗ります
うん
だから、これ
いつも
これから寝ればすぐうまくなる
足長いし
あ、そうか
足長いのすごいポイントなんです
やっぱりこう、ハマりがいい
うんうん
そうよね
ちょっとダメだな
笑
日本人は足短いし
から
ドイツの馬とかに乗っちゃうと
うん